[tense music]
[spray paint sound]
What are you doing?
[muffled]
What's up is I thought we agreed
bike parades are stupid.
[muffled]
Don't lie, Kenny!
You saw that Larry kid scoring
chicks with his bike,
heard about the cash prize,and
you decided to do the
bike parade behind our backs.
I know, 'cause I thought the
same thing!
Me too.
Jesus. Is this really what it's
come down to, you guys?
Whatever happened to us?
What do you mean?
It used to always be the four of
us.
Always.
Now Stan's moved to a farm, I
have anxiety,
Kenny, nobody really talks to
Kenny,
and then there's just Kyle.
We used to do everything
together.
What if we did this like the old
days?
Four bikes. One common theme.
We could totally own the bike
parade.
Yeah!
If we order everything online we
can have it delivered tomorrow!
we need props, pyrotechnics, the
works!
Yeah, and we gotta order some
badass spokes
and those wheel bumpers.
I'll start looking for costumes.
What theme are we thinking?
Kenny, get on your moms laptop
and start ordering
streamers, sparklers and
rockets!
Make sure everyone ships next
day delivery
This is going to be just like
the old times, you guys.